il a d'abord été conseiller à
l'intérieur puis obligatoire dans les
espaces clos
certaines rues et finalement partout à
l'extérieur le sujet du port du masque
sème la confusion
à tel point que mercredi le tribunal du
bas rhin a retoqué partiellement un
arrêté préfectoral datant du 28 août
dernier il imposer le port généralisé du
masque à strasbourg et dans douze autres
villes du département
de plus de 10000 habitants pour le juge
il n'est pas légal d'exposer les
personnes ne portant pas de masque à une
amende en tout lieu et à toute heure du
jour et de la nuit
allant même jusqu'à dire je cite que
c'est une atteinte immédiate à la
liberté d'aller et de venir
la préfète du département est donc dans
l'obligation de réécrire en partie son
arrêté
de son côté le chef de l' oms appelle
les gouvernements à dialoguer avec les
antilles masque tout en rappelant à ces
derniers que le virus est bien réelle
nous devrions écouter ce que les gens
demandent ce que les gens disent nous
devrions engager un dialogue honnête et
en même temps à ceux qui ont manifesté
la semaine dernière je voudrais dire que
le virus est réel qu'il est dangereux
qui se déplace vite et qu'il tue il sera
donc très important pour rester en avant
sur le virus d'éviter les événements
amplificateur ou de prendre le maximum
de précautions lorsque nous voudrons
organisée suite à un regain de
l'épidémie de covin 19 durant la période
estivale plusieurs villes françaises ont
rendu obligatoire le port du masque
à l'extérieur une mesure sanitaire qui
concerne désormais près de 13000 200
communes de 88 départements mais la
décision du tribunal du bas rhin
pourrait faire jurisprudence dans
d'autres communes de france à marseille
lyon nice ou encore paris une quinzaine
de recours contre le port du masque
obligatoire en extérieur ont été
déposées ces dernières semaines d'autres
décisions de ce type pourrait donc se
multiplier